hey everyone its Warren and welcome to
my second segment of Theory Thursday I
have to say I was completely overwhelmed
with how much support you have shown me
and this new segment I got almost a
thousand emails from all of you
submitting your theories for Theory
Thursday and they're all awesome I read
as many as I could and will continue to
read the rest of them to choose theories
for the following Theory Thursdays it's
very clear that I'm going to have to go
over more than five theories each
Thursday but for this month I'm going to
keep it to five so the competition stays
fair if you're new to Theory Thursdays
let me explain how it works if you have
a theory of your own you can submit it
to cosmic Theory Thursdays at gmail.com
each week I will go over five different
theories this will change the ten in the
future at the end of the video you will
vote on the one that you like the most
the winner will then be put into the
pool of Champions and then at the end of
the month you will vote again from the
pool of champions on what theory you
like the most and that winner will win
the overall month and the winner will
get a shout out and a prize right now
the prize is an IMAX gift card so you
and a friend can go see Captain Marvel
or Avengers in Gaiman IMAX at the end of
the video there will be a poll where you
can vote on your favorite theory so
those are the rules you can also find
them in the description down below last
week's winner was theory number two from
gleaming dust with and ant-man theory
Congrats gleaming dust you are now in
the pool of champions all right let's
get started with some theories theory
number one comes from Karthik Sunil
cartax theory states that Ant Man will
run into dr. strange in the quantum
realm the reasoning behind this theory
comes from an interview that Benedict
Cumberbatch and Tom Holland had with
access and during this interview we find
out that Benedict Cumberbatch had a lot
of lines about the quantum realm though
you have to be honest what he was giving
you lines though you have to talk about
so much quantum realm stuff just so I
just have to talk about yeah man that's
awesome this is cool come on it's easy
whoo so as you can see here Benedict and
Tom are talking about who messed up more
lines while filming and as you heard Tom
says that Benedict had the most
difficult lines because he had to talk
about so much quantum realm stuff and
Karthik goes on to say that dr. strange
never talked about any quantum realm
stuff and Avengers infinity war or
anything even remotely close to the
quantum realm and as many of you know
they filmed Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game at the same time so
that must mean that dr. strange talks a
lot about the quantum realm in avengers
endgame it's clearly stated that he had
a lot of lines about the quantum realm
we never heard them an infinity war so
he must state them in Avengers in game
and in the movie Doctor Strange the
ancient one actually sent Doctor Strange
into the quantum realm at one point
although it was very brief he was there
so cartax theory states that ant-man
will run into dr. strange in the quantum
realm and strains will show ant-man how
to use a time vortex karthik ends the
theory by stating that this is why
Captain America is looking at the
picture of Peggy Carter in the Avengers
and game trailer
Captain America now knows that time
travel is possible so he's thinking
about Peggy
so that's Theory number one now on to
theory number two theory number two
comes from Stewart groves Stewart's
theory states that once ant-man gets out
of the quantum realm and Tony Stark
eventually gets back to earth they will
combine their technologies Scott Lang
will show Tony Stark Hank Pym technology
and Tony Stark will then use that
technology to figure out a way to travel
to different dimensions they'll go to
different dimensions so they can collect
their own Infinity stones he also said
that he doesn't think ant-man
is a scroll and he doesn't think ant-man
who we saw in the Avengers in-game
trailer is from the past he thinks it's
current time ant-man due to the fact
that he shows up with his van a lot of
people think that ant-man and the
Avengers in game trailer is a scroll due
to the fact that he should be stuck in
the quantum realm at the present moment
but I also agree I don't think ant-man
is a scroll because I don't think a
scroll shape-shifting into ant-man would
take his van or even know where it is
for that fact because after the snap
it's just stuck on a rooftop his theory
goes on to state that when Captain
America and Black Widow are talking in
the Avengers
game trailer they are talking about a
plan saying this is going to work
Stuart's theory is that once the
Avengers have the Infinity stones from
different dimensions they will ambush
Thanos on its farm on Titan 2 the
Avengers will use the Infinity stones
that they have to combat the Infinity
stones that Thanos has there has been
talk of alternate dimensions for a very
long time now the very first supposed
plot leak that we got mentioned
alternate dimensions and if you think
about it time travel is kind of tricky
especially when it comes to the Infinity
stones because if you change something
in the past it'll affect the future for
example if you change something with the
mine stone the Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver may never get their powers
and vision may never be born The
Avengers may realize this and realize
that they actually can't go back in time
to get the stones instead they have to
go to an alternate dimension to get the
stones
so that's theory number 2 from Stewart
groves on to Theory number 3 number 3
comes from Lewis prick who has a theory
on how the opening scenes of Avengers
endgame will go the theory states that
in the opening scene of Avengers endgame
pepper will receive a message in
hologram form from Tony Stark and she
starts crying and says Oh Tony she then
looks at one of the suits and says
Friday cut to the next scene it seems in
on cap crying and a shot at Bruce Banner
facepalm meanwhile looking at their
missing list then ant-man pops up and
the Avengers let him in once he's in he
starts telling The Avengers how he got
stuck inside of the quantum realm he
explains that in order to get out he had
to go through a time vortex which sent
him back in time
he then found Hank Pym and together they
figured out a way to control the time
travel ant-man explains that once he got
back to the present time everything was
different and he couldn't find anybody
that he knew then Natasha Steve and
banner explained everything that
happened Thanos and the snap and how
they don't know what to do then Scott
says I might have a solution and pulls
out a few bracelets captain asks what
are those and Scott says in the quantum
realm they can take you back in time
Steve and banner look at each other and
then it cuts to a scene with Pepper
Potts flying into space with an Iron Man
suit next to her so this theory actually
incorporates those mysterious bracelets
that we saw and some of the first leaked
photos for avengers endgame in these
photos we see Steve Rogers Tony
starke Bruce Banner and Scott Lang in
what appears to be the Battle of New
York from the first Avengers movie so it
appears like they went back in time and
they're all wearing these weird
bracelets on their hands and these
bracelets are believed to be how they
travel back in time so this theory
incorporates the bracelets into it and
we've also seen a leaked photo of Pepper
Potts wearing some sort of armor so it
seems like she'll be wearing the rescue
armor as well so that's it for theory
number three theory number four comes
from Austin Green he's 16 and lives in
South Carolina and this theory has a
very interesting take on Avengers
endgame Austin states that nebula and
Tony are floating through space and what
if while they're floating through space
they run into Thanos Thanos is on Titan
too which probably isn't too far from
Titan one which is where Tony and nebula
are coming from so they run into Thanos
but fan OHS has already finished his job
he balanced the universe so he doesn't
want to fight he just wants to be left
alone so he sends them back to earth
using the space stone once they meet up
with the rest of the Avengers they begin
to prepare a plan to go against Thanos
but since the snap the universe is now
vulnerable and this is where the second
threat comes in the second threat
threatens the entire universe so Thanos
goes to the Avengers but gauntlet is too
damaged to undo the snap but the time
stone still works so feyo's will go back
in time with the Avengers to stop
himself from doing the snap we do know
that a new threat is coming and we did
see at the end of infinity war that the
gauntlet is damaged it's also really
expected that famous will somehow work
with the Avengers so you never know this
could happen
so that's theory number four and now on
to the next and final theory number five
theory number five comes from Seth
Martin and it's another ant-man in the
quantum realm theory but this one is
very different his theory is that while
ant-man is stuck inside of the quantum
realm he will eventually go look for a
time vortex but the time vortex is
actually Chronos for those of you who
are not aware of who Chronos is he's a
cosmic entity who is the master of time
but he's also fan OSes grandfather
Chronos is a cosmic entity of time and
the universe so he might have a problem
with his grandson eliminating half of
the universe so Seth stayed
that Chronos actually helps ant-man so
the Avengers can undo Thanos a snap he
also says that Chronos could have
perhaps made the time stone as well so
that does it for theory number five and
all of the theories for this week's
Theory Thursday these were some great
theories this week let's do a quick
recap theory number one was about
ant-man meeting dr. strange inside of
the quantum realm theory number two was
about ant-man and Tony Stark figuring
out how to travel in two different
dimensions gathering all of the Infinity
stones going back to the current
dimension and ambushing Thanos on his
farm number three was about the opening
scenes of Avengers in game where Scott
gives everybody time travel bracelets
and Pepper Potts goes into space to save
Tony number four is where Tony and
nebula actually run into Thanos and he
sends them back to earth with the space
stone but then the greater threat comes
and Thanos actually has to work with the
Avengers to undo his own snap and theory
number five is with the cosmic entity
Chronos being the time vortex inside of
the quantum realm so those were this
week's theories don't forget to vote in
the poll at the end of this video on
which one you like the most and again if
you have theories of your own that you
want to submit you can send them to
cosmic Theory Thursdays at gmail.com and
they just might end up an episode of
Theory Thursdays don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
Theory Thursdays and everything related
to Marvel DC and everything superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you